of course it's the typical move you play  Queen G6 and you realize what you have  done  on the board  this is a really bad blender I mean when  you had the chance to play Bishop takes  E4 yeah and and okay some small minor  issues but okay for Magnus Thunder it  shouldn't be and then oh my God  wow I missed it Magnus missed it tadash  did not miss it  I think  C6 is brutal yeah I mean yeah Queen c6s  the queen yeah and and then he's coming  but of course Wesley goes for Dukes the  text takes rookie six will be bleeds out  and then okay and probably Magno  shouldn't be blitzing out anything he  has to now adjust to the new situation  but your defense was looking six I I  don't want the board